[Music]
did you guys know that influencers are
now what can we create an intro for buzz
JK news thank you very much underscore
like that man it should be like buzz JK
Nitro I like that second half of the day
yeah we get on delirious okay what I was
trying to say and I forgot oh yeah did
you guys know that influencers are now
leaving their Instagram and social media
accounts in their will what would I do
like every stockpiled pictures like how
Elvis stockpiled songs or Tupac or
whatever I'll leave everything in my in
my beneficiary [ __ ] to my sister what
the [ __ ] you gonna do in my account know
that guys take a bunch of extra pictures
that Instagram was gonna be around that
long dude there's a YouTube channel that
I watched for years
okay of this older cat and he's like
this huge guy he's huge as [ __ ] he's
like he's built like a goddamn I don't
know like a sumo wrestler almost but
he's this white dude who cooks like
Cajun [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] and he every
week he's like hey today we're making
butter with potatoes and butter and
butter and every week it's like that
right and all of a sudden about like a
year ago he's topped being in the videos
and it's his wife and like her friend in
every single video and all the comments
got to say cuz the wife and friend are
like trying to keep it all going cuz he
obviously died
this cat died young because of all that
butter I got damn right he died because
of the butter yeah yeah so so it's so
fascinating because anytime I found a
couple of videos where the comments
weren't there and like yo where the [ __ ]
is the Cajun man and all this [ __ ] isn't
that like cooking with the dog cooking
with dog all right cooking I know you're
talking about like I've never seen it
but David always talks about David and
Joe always talk about it and the dogs
not there and the dog passed away but
now they have a stuffed animal dog and
the guy is much more sad the problem is
I miss the guy talking about butter like
he's gonna [ __ ] it
you know manage that car yeah we're
about to pull a lotta fun
we're about to put a lot of different
bar on this you're gonna need is a warm
glass oh no low well I can't like a
little bit like warm butter and phlegm
stuck in the back because it cleaners
he's down on the [ __ ] and he's like oh
[Music]
we want tickets I'm about to go down on
this blue wheel man I'm on it's not a
[ __ ] I exist that nothing improve by
just a little bit of brown butter spread
it out over there and go away I'm like
there's this website for a UK cuz they
do in British pounds but if you put if
you enter your Instagram account they
will tell you how much it's worth
that's a cut like the social Bluebook
for your impression the actual selling
price because if I recall correctly
Megan ranks channels I sold for $500
right yeah your video tell the butcher
goodbye that's all for Judy
Megan ranks Shanna's channel with
anything like 2 million I know this one
was the 580 thousand five hundred eighty
thousand but still half a million that's
just sold for 500
like the hacked like underground price
it's cheaper maybe I don't know
the sheer back but obviously I'm gonna
shop for the best price should they did
that because I know they're gonna be
able to get that [ __ ] right back did she
get it back I think she posted an update
video recently we'll find out I think
cuz the she knows and she did yeah so
this one there is no right there saying
that Instagram is Instagram worth it's
calculated based on a value of zero
point zero zero three three per follower
and this is pounds so I did put I want
to know yeah but we have good
interaction it's just that yours is the
first one that sucked in my head all
thank you okay mine is worth is valued
at one thousand Gina darling
yours is one thousand oh is that this
Gina darling or a hello Gina darling cuz
you guys got to put miss Gina valued at
1730 7.39 British Pound okay what's a
deal money don't put me in dopamine now
don't let me out of your no list where
they're like okay here are the ones that
we need to get to you more no like
together
yeah then mmm sorry 37 euros how much is
that Bitcoin far less especially today
we had so this website that I'm putting
these numbers in it's their the title of
this page is influencer wills or wills
port influencer so now you can add your
Instagram account to your will and then
we all just got hacked by the way we're
talking about their services and so
people like to Juna Cristiano Ronaldo
has the most followed account on yes I
did
pull up some photos please soccer man
keep that 207 point 1 million folio hm
didn't believe it figured it's the
biggest word in the world I thought it
would be like Beyonce or something right
or what Jesus just said that people fall
for that soccer thing I think it's just
the face and why just gonna totally be
mom about the soccer take me around
I guess he's not my type tell everyone
you got 200 million he's like hey I'm
here to [ __ ] you you're like no I want
you to kick me around like a soccer ball
she's at 177 Ariana Grande 77 wait how
much is crystianna's account 0-7 207 so
she's 30 million behind - but how much
does he work how much I want to see that
how much I got to pay to buy his account
so that I can blackmail him and to sleep
in with me they not give him his account
300,000 let me record 500,000 oh I can
record it 6645 close how water 646
Germany sit oh you want to keep guessing
higher no that's why 688 six hundred
eighty eight thousand nine hundred and
eighty three British Pam shake he could
get that from one brand deal day he'd
get it poppin and that's actually what
their it seems to be that they're
calculating is that like this is kind of
what a post is worth if the person's
still alive and they're speaking from
themselves yeah like you know like it
really isn't the same if you found out
your person died and then like a family
member took over their account as ghosts
yeah I think it would still kind of like
you know the estate's look at my friend
in a state or whatever like they're
still making money as I was saying like
if they had songs that were still left
over like Tupac did or whatever without
pictures that were still left over or
what if there was like a weird future
where it's like they had all these
unreleased photos of this influence
and then you just Photoshop a product
and then the product pays for that to go
up that's why I was singing that like
it's like a weird futuristic thing we're
like you pay this service and it
continues mont your memorial on your
page but it'll still do brand deals and
all the money goes back to your family
yeah so like an estate like the music
stuff which I'll do that though or is it
too creepy oh I'm down as I support my
family [ __ ] do it sounds like what My
Damn Channel did them Daily Grace yeah
they just reload her old videos everyday
and then everyone's like [ __ ] you we
know she left this channel [ __ ] yourself
yeah I want you to deep fake my face and
see someone's body with like a badass
and big-ass titties I just don't do that
for you do you want to see yourself
getting [ __ ] to him sure there's a
little huggy up make some money for my
family I'm down ok if there's a port you
they start a pornhub in your name right
it's like you've never made any
important videos but they can be fake it
I mean they're doing that now yeah you
sign off your permission for a deep fake
to help your family you get it out like
a million dollars by port huh isn't that
kind of sad but kind of beautiful at the
same time it really is it's also scary I
want I want my dad to get that check
every month like well yeah I mean that's
just the kind of future that were we're
in guys maybe point would you do porn
what i do porn at any point of course
yeah yeah with who just me or with other
people only maybe what if it was with
you and then what if it was with
somebody else somebody that look like
you solo cam jerk-off videos obviously
what god
oh what if it was like a weekly thing
where you guys have a different partner
every week no [ __ ] absolutely way why
not
I'm not into that okay what if they like
get tested in everything even if it's
two girls or whatever the [ __ ] it's not
leave us a comment below if you would
subscribe to Nikki and Steve's only fans
account thousand times over
DNA isn't aware is that somebody's
hoping that accent was so thick you
should have a only fans account like
read them based on like Wisconsin novel
to me well for st. Louis okay I felt
that I'm in Springfield all right that's
it yeah would you do to only only chance
yeah would you do only fans account I
don't know what they will pay for like
just like what girls you guys like have
so much sex appeal to see yeah
get them dress up in lingerie let me
just like dig so like it would just be
like me like yeah nobody's there for the
guy ever never
a bouquet of roses Steve's earlier idea
just like just just putting it next to
things he was like like mana but guy is
as a fan it's a if a guy is a fan of a
girl like he wants to see her do porn or
whatever like he wants to see her naked
but if a girl like if I'm a fan of a guy
I want to see him [ __ ] another girl I
want you to tell me that you did the
dishes and you ran the errands for us oh
I would do I would just do all I would
do only fan videos well great sweat song
while I'm like cleaning up do those
really corny ones it those those kids
were doing on vine for a minute where
they just look in the camera there like
hey beautiful I hope you had a great
date
I don't want that I need you to
disrespect me anywhere they just start
like [ __ ] right right Oh Gina you
want POV like huh I forgot to do the
dishes again didn't you [ __ ] I want to
be disrespected yeah what's your spin
camera are we hitting the videos I've
been hitting the camera on my videos I
don't Instagram so I would just do that
with my painters own only fans like
who's been a bad girl hey guys real
quick I gotta go on break cuz I hit my
penis really hard so there's my ass my
brakes on I'll be right there
if you get come in your eye it turns red
though so yeah be careful it's true also
that's a sign of disrespect Regina yeah
what company yeah both eyes look it
[Laughter]